I think if you are a true food lover you
are a healthy year well first of all the
term foodie is a completely ridiculous
because for someone that when you meet
somebody and they say I really love to
eat I think the appropriate answer is
who doesn't so I mean look around who
you know who's not a food lover
everybody's a food lover the question is
do you eat responsibly do you eat for
your own benefit to eat for your
planet's benefit and do you eat the best
food possible if the answer to all of
those things is yes then you're eating
well if you're eating you know if your
style of eating is bad for your body if
your style of eating is bad for the
planet then you are not really eating
good food you're eating lousy food and
there's as we know there's plenty of
lousy food around
the the principle the principled way to
eat if you were going to say I want to
eat entirely for my own benefit I want
to eat entirely for the benefit of the
planet I want to eat in the most
responsible way possible to minimize my
carbon footprint to minimize my impact
overall to minimize my effect on animals
you would be a vegan that's the bottom
line the veganism is the most principled
way to eat that there is from the
perspective of your own body from the
perspective of the planet from the
perspective of animals very few people
are going to be vegans let's be real so
what's next I mean if on the one end you
have vegans and on the other hand you
have people who eat whatever they feel
like eating there's a middle ground the
problem with the way most Americans eat
right now is that we are about as far
from veganism as we could be so a vegan
would get one hundred percent of his or
her calories from plants most Americans
get ninety percent of their calories
from processed food junk food and animal
products so the the goal i think is to
move in the direction of eating more
unprocessed plant food than we do now
and everybody's got a different starting
place if you eat 20 cheeseburgers a week
or the equivalent you might look at
eating 15 cheeseburgers a week or the
equivalent if you're eating 15 you might
look at eating 10 and so on and I think
if people think about what's best for
their body what's best for the planet
the answer is eating unprocessed plant
food and then think about how can I eat
more of that stuff at the expense of
meat which was you know which was the
question but also at the expense of
processed food and junk food
the idea is to eat as many unprocessed
plants as you can what are plants plants
are vegetables fruits legumes which
means beans nuts and seeds what am i
leaving out I think that's about it so
the idea is to eat as many unprocessed
plants as you possibly can and to eat
those instead of eating processed foods
junk foods and animal products what
works for me what's worked for me for
just about three years now what works
for me is to eat very very strict diet
of plants only and unprocessed plants
only from the time I wake up in the
morning until dinnertime so from the
time I wake up until roughly dark I eat
a lot of fruit I had a lot of vegetables
they eat some whole grains and sometimes
I have some beans and that's pretty much
it and then at night ate whatever I want
and that's which includes meat and which
includes wine and which includes pasta
and bread and stuff like that that's a
huge change for me I think that if you
think of your diet is a seesaw with the
you know the animal products the process
with the junk food on the heavy side as
it is for most people and the
unprocessed plants on the light side as
it is for most people I think for me my
see-saw went from looking something like
this to looking something like this I
think that to the extent other people
can eat that way they will have a have a
lesser impact on the planet improve
their health probably lose weight feel
better
think um i decided to change the way
because of some of the things we've been
talking about here one is that I
recognized that one of the highest
contributors to greenhouse gases in
global warming is the is the industrial
production of livestock so I decided
okay that was one good reason to eat
less meat the other good reasons he
lists meat is that I was in my mid 50s
and my health wasn't what it used to be
so I was overweight I had bad knees I
had sleep apnea I had high cholesterol I
had high blood sugar borderline high
blood sugar I think that's enough so I
decided to change my diet and it's uh
it's so obvious to everyone who pays any
attention to nutrition at all that if
you want to be healthier the way to do
that is you know as I've already said is
to eat fewer animal products and eat
less processed in junk food so I started
to do that and and it worked I lost 35
pounds um Game five of them back but hey
I slept sleep apnea went away I slept
better my knees bothered me much less in
fact Iran new york marathon last year my
cholesterol is back to normal and my
blood Sugar's back to normal so it all
worked and it's not a coincidence I mean
no one would say it was a coincidence
actually not um there are some things I
don't like but I think that it's
important to recognize that there's no
sort of single I mean arsenic and
cyanide aside there's not really a
single ingredient that's going to
outright kill you i mean there's
actually some evidence that a single can
of soda can trigger diabetes but there's
not a lot of eps evidence about that in
general one ingredient one little kind
of food 11 meal one day even one week
that's not what's determinant of your
overall health or of your impact on the
planet what determines is your overall
diet and if it's moving in the right
direction which for most Americans is
towards plants and away from animal
products and processed foods then I
think you know hip hip hooray you know
that's the way to go